most of us exist in this space of
endless comparison the compare and
despair right so we have either these
idealized versions of ourselves that
we're constantly comparing ourselves to
or the folks that we see on social media
that we have these warped notions of how
perfect they are and that we're never
measuring up you have to stop
conditioning yourself
and stop speaking yourself into i don't
have enough time you're exhausted you're
burnt out you just feel like i've got
nothing else to give and i'm like this
is not how we're designed to live
there's like what's the point
and there she is
in the house we're back how are you i
was just listening to you talk about
wednesdays and that's your project day
yeah so i like chunking i mean we're
going to talk a lot about time
management here today but i like
chunking my days out
my tuesdays are youtube day and it's
just video video video video non-stop
like in the studio we're creating like
crazy and thursdays tomorrow are always
interviews and podcasts and shows and
crazy crazy crazy so like the one day in
the middle
is project day so it's great creativity
day a lot of open time
whatever i want to work on i go and and
work on it one of those things i want to
work on is talking to marie forleo about
what she's up to
um the last time he came on so we we did
this on instagram we put it to youtube's
got over half a million views now which
is super exciting um you just came out
of your surgery out of you know that
crazy
life change for you and and now you're
here launching new program time genius
give us the quick update on what's new
in the world of marie forleo oh it's
going so good first of all fall is one
of my favorite seasons and now that it's
officially here and i'm like looking
around in my neighborhood and the trees
are just starting to turn and the
pumpkins are coming out so from a just
life perspective things feel really
fresh and good and i feel like this time
of year is always so reminiscent for
many of us about like going back to
school and kind of digging back in and
diving into learning new things and so
company wise we are in the midst of uh
we're so excited this new program that's
called time genius which is really
giving people a paradigm shift around
time so they can be joyfully productive
so whether you're an entrepreneur or
you're an employee you know one of the
things that i just was noticing for
honestly
the past five or six years but it feels
like it keeps it's it's kept getting
more intense and more intense over time
was just hearing myself and then hearing
other people i talked to
always express this feeling of being
behind of feeling overstretched of
feeling over committed like they can't
ever catch up
that there's so much to do there's so
little time people feeling stressed out
burnt out some people having health
challenges talking to other fellow
entrepreneurs and people going like god
you know the pace that i used to keep
and it feels like there's just so much
coming at me all the time between emails
and social and incoming and potential
projects and my family it just all
started to feel like too much and i was
like there's something wrong here
because i'm a smart person you're a
smart person
so many of people in our audience we are
intelligent we're earnest we're
hard-working but it's like something
wasn't matching up and i was feeling
like this
culture
has us believing some things that are
just simply unsustainable
and you know what's happening in the
personal can oftentimes be happening in
the global as well and i think it's
there's some interesting parallels there
between the fact that you know how we're
operating
many of us has been an unsustainable
type of setup in terms of working way
too many hours not taking enough breaks
and constantly feeling or believing like
we're not enough and i know belief is so
big for you evan that is your theme that
is one of your biggest mantras is
helping people believe in themselves and
you know the power of beliefs right if
you believe that there's not enough time
if you believe that you're not doing
enough that you're never getting the
right things done that you're always
behind that is going to be your
experience of life and one of the things
that we know from end of life studies
and we do have this research and we do
have this data
is when people come to the end of their
journey on this plane uh one of their
number one regrets is that they didn't
live their life in a way that was true
to them but in a way that other people
expected of them
and i think for many of us we've been
kind of living adhering to other
people's expectations whether those are
explicit or implicit or just what we
notice other people around us doing for
example this constant drumming of the
message of
24 7 hustle culture and look i love my
work i'm so passionate about it i've
been doing this for 20 years then i
don't plan on stopping anytime soon so
it's not about not loving what you do
but at some point i think again about
five or six years ago i started to
notice it was like this
gross exaggeration this
unattainable unsustainable expectation
that i was like this isn't healthy i
don't want any part of it so time
geniuses is our answer to that
i love it so for the youtube audience
we'll link that in the description below
go check out the time genius down there
it's got to be one of the most common
questions i get asked by entrepreneurs
who are
starting out
trying to juggle everything maybe
already have a job and trying to figure
out
work home kids business like what do you
what do you tell them what do you what's
the advice that you give an entrepreneur
who's like i i have no time marie i have
no time for anything what do i do yes
well first of all it's like that is
actually the first thing that we want to
start to investigate and that's one of
the first things that we want to change
because how we speak to ourselves
it's like we're fish swimming in water
we don't even realize it all the time
and right if you're saying like i don't
have the time i don't have the time i
don't have the time while this sounds
really cliched and simplistic it comes
back to neuroplasticity and what we know
from research and our minds if you say
that constantly you are physically
driving those grooves into your brain
it's kind of like uh you know plowing
snow off of your driveway or railroad
tracks right if you keep drilling that
sentence and sentiment in either you're
saying it in your own head or you're
saying it out loud or simply a
combination and when you're doing it
from a place of emotional intensity like
stress or overwhelm or fear
that is going to be your lived
experience and the more those grooves
get set into place it becomes a pattern
and again something else we know from
research is that we human beings live
about 40 percent of our life out of
habit or pattern so if you keep saying
that then that will be your experience
whether you're at the beginning of your
journey at the middle of your journey
when your business actually starts
working and you're like oh my god i got
to grow it i've got to hire a team right
and i have all these projects that i
have to do and then even if you're more
seasoned as an entrepreneur that groove
will still be there and you'll still
create it so the first place we need to
look is you have to stop
conditioning yourself
and stop speaking yourself into i don't
have enough time
so here's a mantra that i use and it's
helped me
amazingly when it comes to kind of
backing out of overwhelm and starting to
change my own habits and my own thoughts
around this is that i always have time
for what's most important
i always have time for what's most
important so yes there might be a lot on
your plate right now but if you come
from a space of i always have time for
what's most important
it slows you down
it helps you kind of dial back on the
stress and what that mantra
intrinsically prompts you to figure out
is well what's most important so there's
kind of a lot embedded under there in
terms of
helping us realize that first of all not
everything can be important because that
would actually defy the definition of
priorities right you can't have multiple
priorities there needs to be one
but second it helps you start to decide
well what is most important at this
stage and season in my life so if you're
at the beginning
it might be about going like okay
i can't expect myself to do an hour
workout every day and meditate twice a
day for 20 minutes and then be the most
perfect parent um you know walk my dog
for an hour every day it might be about
giving yourself the grace and space to
recognize i'm starting a business this
is a really heavy lift maybe i also have
a job on the side too which is also a
very heavy lift
where can i release some of the pressure
and the expectations that i have on
myself to be a super person superman
superwoman superhuman
and create a little bit of a runway so i
can say you know what for the next six
months i'm not going to work out every
single day of the week but maybe i'm
going to work out three days a week and
on the off days i'm going to take a walk
around the block or do something really
light or do a five minute workout and
that's going to be enough
how can i enlist my family or my friends
to support me because this is really an
important long-term goal and maybe
you're not going to do a home-cooked
meal every single night or your kids or
other people can pitch in or you can do
potlucks right it's about kind of using
that figure outable philosophy but i
think where we get ourselves into
trouble generally speaking in terms of
where we start is we don't recognize the
power we have in our own minds in our
own bodies and our own ability to speak
our reality into existence and of course
that doesn't dismiss the very real
challenges that we have with like
there's only 24 hours in a day we need
sleep but if you don't start with what
you can control on the inside which
includes your mind and your heart and
your beliefs
nothing on the outside will ever be
enough you can't change your
circumstances enough you wouldn't be
able to get less hours on the job
because that same
belief track which is i don't have
enough time i don't have enough time i
don't have enough time we'll still be
running so you can move the chess pieces
around exteriorly but if you don't
change this first you're never going to
have what we like to call in time genius
the experience of being joyfully
productive what does that mean
that means the experience of like what
you're talking about where you're like
i've got my projects to do today right
today is a day where i get to create
something i get to be present in my life
i get to be there with my kids my
partner my loved one and not be looking
at my phone or my computer or thinking
that i should be 5 or 10 or 20 different
other places or beating myself up
because i didn't get enough done at work
so now i'm really not present but i'm
wanting to get back there that's what we
want to go for in time genius it's
really an inside out transformation i
love it marie forleo is preaching here
ladies and gentlemen i love it it's
great
talk to me about
judgment okay so
yesterday for example i spent maybe a
quarter of my day
listening to
pet shop boys go west
at 1.25 speed for whatever reason and it
led me down this rabbit hole that
eventually led to this really cool new
idea that i could bring to
my customers but it was a lot of mess
and there was no
real intention with it just besides i
like this so i'm going to listen to the
song on repeat for whatever reason and
somebody asked me doesn't that feel like
a waste of time
um and some things that sometimes it
leads somewhere and sometimes it doesn't
and my best answer is really i don't
know i don't judge myself for following
my creativity but i don't really know
how to teach that component so
so many people are judging themselves
for not being a better mom or not being
a better entrepreneur or not being a
better husband or wife or whatever how
do we start to loosen the judgment
because when you say well i'm not going
to do a home-cooked meal today then that
boy so now i'm a crappy mom or dad if i
didn't make that meal so how do we get
over the judgment to then start making
our time more effective i think it
becomes uh really about self-compassion
and i didn't expect this to be such a
big part of the time genius program when
i was putting it together but one of the
themes that we talk about consistently
is how when you're in the time genius
zone you have so much self-compassion
you have so much kindness for you
because what you're talking about really
evan is the fact that most of us exist
in this space of endless comparison the
compare and despair right so we have
either these idealized versions of
ourselves that we're constantly
comparing ourselves to
or the folks that we see on social media
that we have these warped notions of how
perfect they are and that we're never
measuring up so i think it comes back to
understanding if you actually are
engaging in that compare and despair and
go i'm not doing that today like not
today no who i am is enough me showing
up and being present in this enough and
really taking a step back
to challenge the assumptions that you
have in your head about who you're
supposed to be like where did those
ideas come from and if you actually slow
yourself down and investigate that and
you have the courage to be honest with
yourself
you will uncover exactly who you're
comparing yourself to or those outdated
definitions of success that you might
have formed when you were a kid about
for example you know my mom is an
amazing human god bless her she's still
alive
her
greatest joy and some of her greatest
goals in life were around having a
family she wanted to have a family so
cooking a home-cooked meal every single
night making sure that the house was how
she wanted it taking care of things so
that my dad and my brother and myself
that we were okay like that was her
life's goal and aspiration
and it's not mine but as a young girl i
was thinking like oh well that's what it
means to be a successful woman because
that was the example that i saw
and again you can do the same thing with
social media right if you kind of are
comparing yourself to someone else and
you're going well i'm falling short if
you just challenge that assumption and
ask like where am i getting this idea
from
why am i believing that who i am as a
human being is not enough and going like
no i'm more than enough this
self-compassion piece my journey is
unique so me as an individual talking
about my mom you know i knew very
clearly when i was young that i didn't
necessarily want to get married and i
didn't necessarily want to have kids
which was a huge departure from my kind
of familial
script from my italian american
family right
and so that takes work to have the
courage to define success for yourself
and to keep this is really a practice to
keep clearing out that compare and
despair
that fills up so much of our world
because we are on things like this like
this is a beautiful form of social media
in my opinion where you and i not only
get to have this conversation we have
these beautiful people here this is also
going to be on youtube so there'll be
more beautiful people that we'll be
connecting with and we can learn ideas
from each other and share possibilities
that's awesome when it comes to
technology and social but i think we'd
be remiss if we didn't also talk about
the flip side of it right how many of us
can use these platforms to measure
ourselves against other people and then
come up short and all of a sudden our
lives are somehow not enough when in
reality it's that thought that's
creating the pain not the reality of our
circumstances and that's all an inside
job so i know that was a very kind of
long answer no it's great yeah if that
helped because the moment you catch
yourself saying i'm not enough because
and you have the wisdom and you slow
down enough to find out who you're
comparing yourself to why you're
thinking that that's the beginning of
kind of untangling the naughtiness of of
that
pain-filled thought pattern
well i i love like the long answer is
fantastic because it gives depth it's
not just a one-liner i mean we love the
marie quotables too and share those and
you're great at it but the the depth of
knowledge is great to help people
actually make the next step
you know your mantra for the first part
was
i always have time for what's important
for what would important
right what would what would your mantra
be for this for the judgment piece
so let's see we can create one and i
think one of the best things you know
about mantra so mine always come out of
just uh this
wildly configured brain and heart
and i always encourage people to make
their own but for me it's like um
i'm doing my life the very best i can
i'm doing my life the very best i can
and once it comes back to my life for me
that sentence helps
seat me
in the uniqueness of my own journey
right i'm doing my life to the very best
i can and it kind of re-roots me in the
fact that my journey is distinct from
everyone else's
my journey is mine alone and god the
universe creator whatever you believe in
smurf fairies
my core belief is that i was put here
for a very unique reason
my path is unlike anyone else's and the
moment i start comparing myself to other
people the moment i get into
me versus them i'm miserable there's no
creativity that's possible i don't feel
good about myself i'm not contributing
i'm not connecting to the people i'm
actually with i'm just stuck in this
mental emotional sinkhole of feeling
like crap and from that space it's like
nothing good is possible so um that
would be that was just a little made-up
mantra in the moment i don't know if
that's what i'd stick with but that
would be like my first draft i like it i
like it i like it um
let's go down a sister path here
of procrastination so a lot of people
are and i know you covered in time
genius a lot of people are
stock procrastinating a lot of it is
just that overthinking that comparison
over thinking so if somebody's just got
this great idea they know they're
capable of more they've got this in them
they want to serve they want to do it
all the right reasons and yet it's like
i just can't
make the video or write that book or
like there's always something there's
always some mental block so what do you
advise entrepreneurs who are stuck in
their head and and can't get over
procrastination procrastination this is
a really good one so first layer
is to actually do a check-in with
yourself
do you actually want to reach this goal
or have this experience i think that is
a first level gut check because
sometimes we can see that other people
have something they've experienced
something we might feel that little pang
of envy or jealousy and think that we
want it to
but then uh we don't really want it
right it's like if you're not actually
doing something you have to really do a
gut check like do i really want this so
that would be the first layer of
check-in oftentimes we think we should
want to do something because society has
told us that this is what you do when
you are ex-successful or this is what
you should want when you're going on
this particular path let me give you a
concrete example and then we'll get back
to procrastination so we're going to go
on a little bit of a side trip but
hopefully
so i remember when i was just getting
started in my dance career uh and i was
25 which in the dance world is greatly
over the hill especially when you're
starting in hip hop and street dance and
i just remember going to my first ever
class at broadway dance center in new
york city and this is where all the pros
go and i mean these incredible humans
have been training since like they were
three or four you know and so they're
probably around the age of like 18 or 19
they're complete professionals here i am
at like 25 never taken a professional
dance class in my life and i remember
feeling so intimidated that i almost
didn't do the class a form of
procrastination right just so terrified
and so fearful
finally took the class cried because my
body was so happy to be in there but i
started looking around and i'm like wow
everybody's going on auditions and
everyone's like going on tours and doing
all these things that must be what you
do as a professional dancer and so evan
i started trying to put myself in all of
these different experiences like going
on auditions getting headshots thinking
this is what i have to do but something
didn't feel right it was like i was
chasing these goals that i thought i
should be chasing if i wanted to be a
real dancer
cut to some really unfortunate
situations i made such a fool of myself
i remember this one missy elliott
particular audition that i literally
walked out of the room crying because i
couldn't keep up with all the
choreography it was so mortifying so
embarrassing
fast forward a little bit i still loved
dance but i loved dance in a fitness
environment because it wasn't
necessarily about performing on these
big stages it was actually about
teaching everyday people how to move
their body in such a way where they felt
great and for me that was like my sweet
spot right it was encouraging people it
was teaching them to do something that
they didn't believe they could do
so a few months later this opportunity
came up um nike the company was starting
this new program called the nike
rockstar workout and they were
specifically looking for people who had
a talent when it came to dance and
specifically hip-hop and street dance
and who also were really good at
instructing and motivating
and so i wound up becoming one of the
world's first nike elite dance athletes
but i could have never even become that
if i was chasing another goal to be a
real dancer going on tours and doing
music videos because that wasn't my path
does that make sense so when it comes to
the procrastination discussion i feel
like sometimes we're chasing goals that
the world has set for us but we don't
really want them but we don't know what
else we want it has it takes a lot of
courage to be able to step away from
something everyone thinks you should do
and you're just kind of doing it because
you think it should be the next step but
it's not really your step so that's
level one of procrastination level two
if you definitely want this thing you
wanna write the book you wanna create
the course you wanna start the company
you wanna move to a new country whatever
that goal is and you seem to be
procrastinating about it you gotta put
some bumpers in place and what do i mean
by bumpers i mean that you need
deadlines and most people need support
some form of accountability for me one
of the best forms of accountability is
actually public accountability i learned
this early on in my career one of the
best ways for me to make sure that i
launched a new product was to set a
deadline for when it was going to launch
and then announce it publicly so i would
have to do it other people and i did
this with a project early on in my
career um i wanted to write my first
book and i just found myself not like
kind of wiggling out of actually getting
it done
and the thing that really turned the
corner for me was hiring a book coach
someone that i could check in with and
it was worth that investment of money to
have someone that i respected who i had
to produce pages for who would give me
feedback so i had to put those bumpers
in place in order to move that goal
ahead i think people greatly
underestimate the power of deadlines
deadlines are huge if you don't have one
you need to give yourself one and the
bigger you can make the stakes for not
reaching it the better when it comes to
procrastination so there's just two
little ideas to get people started i
love it and you mentioned courage and i
think a lot of people
they're watching live or they're
watching youtube video and like yeah
that's right i'm gonna go do my thing
i'm gonna you know the energy is real
they're gonna go but then the next day
you wake up and like where did all that
courage go what what i i can't
i'm fooling myself i can't write that
book i can't make a youtube video and
and the the self-doubt starts to creep
in again and the courage seems to be
gone so
obviously getting programs like time
genius link in the description below um
can definitely help in having what you
give as people a road map and it makes
it feel like it's possible it's not this
overwhelming impossible thing that hey
follow these modules and we're going to
teach you how to do it so that is
definitely one step how do you what
what's the next step to
just making it more consistent
in the follow through so it's not just
okay i have the information the time
genius gave me the knowledge how do i
actually follow through on it yeah 100
so if we stick with the procrastination
example for just a moment um i think we
can even take it further one of the
tools that i'll teach you how to use in
time genius is simple and you should use
it right now and to start using it
especially this is especially good for
big projects projects like a book or
something like that that have a pretty
long lead time and there are many
different pieces to it and it can feel
overwhelming and if you fall off the
wagon it's just that road is going to
get longer and longer it's something
called a reverse calendar so what's a
reverse calendar a reverse calendar is a
way to
help yourself
break a big project down into digestible
chunks with all of these many milestones
along the way so that it feels less oh
my god how am i going to get all these
things done and all the ideas are
swirling around in your head and you're
like but the cover and the editor and
this and that you're all over the place
a reverse calendar says what is the date
by which i want to have my first draft
manuscript done you actually open up a
calendar and you see you know whether
it's six months from now three months
from now nine months now whatever but
you have a clear firm deadline date
then you look at whatever the date is
today and you start to reverse engineer
all of the little milestones that you
must hit in order to get that first
draft manuscript on so for me when i was
working on my book everything is
figureoutable i used a version of a
reverse calendar because it helped me
get out of that sense evan of feeling
like oh my gosh there's so much i need
to write like how am i ever going to get
all this done to being able to see a
mini milestone ahead of me where i'm
like if i can just get there and just
focus on that for this next week or two
weeks i can breathe i can be okay and
then once that little mini milestone was
done in my reverse calendar it was like
oh there's the next one
so you were asked about follow through
these are the kinds of tools that we can
use they're all free
that can help us develop that ability to
be consistent and to stay on track with
long-term projects that could really
change the trajectory of our career our
lives but most of us just haven't been
exposed to them and we haven't been
taught either how to set up our entire
life so that it is supportive of
whatever we call in time genius your
primary project of that thing getting
done so one of the other keys actually
to staying consistent is not taking on
too much at once
i think it is a um it's just
i've seen it time and time again with
myself i've seen it with so many folks
in our audience we're super passionate
we're super creative we're super
ambitious and those things are beautiful
traits and we want to honor them and
when you have five big projects that you
want to get done in the next three
months that puts people in a space of
feeling paralyzed and frozen and
overwhelmed and like nothing ever
happens so another piece of that puzzle
of consistency is actually not taking on
too much scaling back and doing what i
call simplify to amplify which we take
you through all that time changes too
i love it
last question talk to me about
joy so yeah you know you talk about time
management and and a lot of the time
engineering principles have been around
forever i think what you're doing with
time genius is making it 2021
relatable
um and also introducing the new science
new technologies
but the the marie magic you know it's is
joy it's like how do you do this and not
just be this super efficient robot but
like that you love your life and nobody
talks about time management and joy
together and when i saw that i was like
yes i love this yeah so so tell us i
mean it may be obvious but tell us why
joy and then how do we put joy
as a as a core value into our calendar
100 well i think it's so important and
honestly the place that we've all been
right for the last 18 months and we
don't know how much longer until as a
global society we can get the pandemic
behind us we don't know where we're at
with that
and uh for me having a joyful life it's
like we work so hard everyone listening
right now they work so hard to take care
of their families to take care of
themselves to try and do their best by
their community and all the people that
they have responsibilities towards and
sometimes i've experienced this where
it's like you're exhausted
you're burnt out you just feel like i've
got nothing else to give and i'm like
this is not how we're designed to live
there's like what's the point do you
know what i mean of working so hard even
if you're making great money or you're
making an impact if you're you yourself
aren't happy and joyful if you're not
having a good time along the way it's
all for naught again i get really
obsessed with those end of life studies
and um because people tell us right we
have this incredible data and research
from thousands of souls who have gone
before us who have reached the end of
their life and they have insight and
wisdom to share and almost all of them
said i think it was maybe like the third
or fourth regret this is bonnie brownie
wears the five regrets of the dying the
top five regrets of the dying almost all
of them said i wished i allowed myself
to be happier
i wish i allowed myself to be happier
and when you really stop and think about
that and i'm paraphrasing a little they
might have not gotten the words
perfectly right but that was the essence
of it
i allowed myself to be happier and evan
i don't know have you experienced this
have you ever gone through periods of
life where you put your head down and
you worked really hard and maybe you
stressed out and you're like
gosh that was done but it wasn't that
enjoyable i mean i certainly have you
know for sure tortured myself i just was
so tight and so constricted and i
realized i'm like
all of these different little seasons of
my life when you string them together
are my life so if i don't train myself
to bring joy to as many moments as
possible it's not always going to happen
and there's some really crappy hard
things that happen in all of our lives
so this is not about being
no toxic positivity this is not about
being unrealistic but there's many times
throughout my day where i'm like i could
be enjoying myself a lot more right like
if i'm working on something i can bring
that party to whatever i'm doing and
oftentimes especially when there's those
tedious tasks that we all have to do
whether it's emptying your dishwasher
doing the laundry pipe breaks right you
have to clean something up these are the
things that all of us go through your
car breaks down something unexpected
happens in your lab oh my goodness
you can either go handle that from a
place of being just angry and upset and
complaining and beating yourself or the
world up why is it like this or i've
decided i'm like
as much as humanly possible i want to
bring the party which means i'm going to
turn on some music i'm going to laugh at
myself i'm going to laugh at life
because stuff happens that you don't
expect and it can either be a show or it
can be like you know what this is life
so i might as well have a good time with
it and i think one of the experiences of
being a time genius is to also
prioritize what brings you joy so is it
laying in the grass and staring at the
clouds is it allowing yourself some
non-guilty time on the couch to watch
your favorite netflix show
is it being with your dog or with your
kids or cooking a meal or just reading a
great novel i think that we did research
with our audience evan and we have
responses from i think at this point
it's over 15 000 folks about how they
feel about their time and i was so
struck by how many people feel guilty
and feel like they're not productive
enough the moment they slow down and try
and take a rest that there was no joy
that they they didn't even feel like
they deserved to feel joyful because any
time that they kind of looked away from
work they had this overwhelming thought
that they should be doing something more
productive so the reason for me to
emphasize joy and time genius is not
because it works but it's also because
it's so necessary i don't want to see
any of us myself you anyone who's
turning tuning in right now
get to the end of their one precious
life and look back and go gosh
i wish i allowed myself to just be
happier
i love it
what a message yeah the legend marie
forleo in the house the program is
called time
genius
youtube will link it up in the
description below thank you marie for
for your time today for injecting so
much joy into my community as well and
i just want to thank you too and you
know the more that i've gotten to know
who you are and what you stand for and
what you believe i just admire you so
much because uh one of the things that
i've learned on this journey it's like
belief really is everything right it's
what we believe about ourselves and that
ability to believe in ourselves and that
it's capable that we're capable of
creating change and being different and
learning and growing and you're just
such an incredible example of that so
thank you for taking the time on your
wednesday project day to have this
conversation it really means the world
i'm working on accepting compliments so
i received that thank you marie
good you deserve it you deserve it and
i'm so grateful for everyone for tuning
in also too depending on when this goes
up and when you check it out if you go
to join dimegenius.com we've got april
friends
jointimegenius.com
we've got a free master class up it's
awesome it's about the um three toxic
lies that keep you overwhelmed
overstretched and under earning and how
to break free now so even if time genius
isn't for you as the program go take
that master class because it'll help you
start to think differently and recognize
all of the ways that uh kind of our
culture has just fed this notion of
constant nonstop work and it's not the
only way to be
i love it join
timegenius.com for the free master class
too we love you marie thank you for
joining thank you so much see you soon
okay bye take care if you want to see
the last one-on-one i did with marie
forleo to see how everything is
figure-out-able check it out right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there modern entrepreneurship can be for
everyone all of us are immersed in a
culture that has taught us that non-stop
work is the most valuable thing